women-owned businesses play a critical
role in the us economy accounting for
1.9 trillion dollars in revenue
and employing 9.4 million people the u.s
chamber of commerce reported that female
small business owners are less
optimistic about their revenue
investment and hiring plans
and have less access to capital than
their male counterparts
against the backdrop of the coveted
pandemic diane von furstenberg teamed up
with amazon for the second year in a row
to spotlight women-owned businesses
on the e-commerce platform the
month-long campaign highlights companies
from several countries including the us
india and spain all of which were
hand-picked by von furstenberg as well
as friends and fellow a-listers like
mindy kaling
it happened last year for international
women's day
i thought that i wanted to do something
for the for women and i thought that
amazon has such a big big theater
and they do help these these women
entrepreneur
so it was a nice thing to highlight them
and it was so successful
that we are anniversary all women are
the same you know we all have the same
issues
and we all have the same problems and
frustrations
and desire and it's about taking charge
and being in charge
so it's really about honoring women in
charge we pick
these are all women who have ideas about
product
and so i picked products that were
little
diverse one is a toy and the other one
is paper the the hot sauce
everyone has an idea and they make it
happen
amazon works with more than 2 million
independent selling partners in the u.s
48 of those are owned by women there
isn't a day that i don't order something
on amazon and that became
even more magnified with the pandemic
and with the newborn
i am completely open about my love of
shopping and
at times even materialism and what uh
you don't always think when you're
someone who
you know loves to shop and loves the
ease of shopping online that you could
do that
and just as easily be helping a young
female
entrepreneur or a new female
entrepreneur by making
a little bit more of an informed choice
you can actually be lifting up
women who are starting their own
businesses and i couldn't be where i am
without the help of women who helped me
when i was starting out so i'm like this
is literally
what a great thing to get behind the
easiest way to help
to help people is just to make more
informed
informed decisions when you're shopping
and i think that a lot of times
at least you know with my friends we're
often like deterred
because they think like okay there's no
one like me who can succeed in this
business but the very thing that makes
them different is what now makes them
really exciting to
massive corporations you know who want
to like throw their weight behind a
company that doesn't
look like other people's companies while
2020 was indisputably one of the most
challenging years on record for small
businesses
amazon says nearly all of the small and
medium-sized businesses
that sell through its platform increase
sales by more than 55 percent
year-over-year it is very important
that we own who we are that we turn our
imperfection into our assets our
vulnerability
into our strengths